[Musique]
cette dame que vous voyez à l'écran ça
fait bizarre c'est une maman non je
devrais dire c'était le moment parce que
elle a perdu son enfant son enfant qui
avait 18 mois tout simplement parce que
son enfant était atteinte du malaria et
il a reçu une injection et après cette
injection
il est décédé ça c'est sa voisine qui
s'appelle il est saine et cette fois ci
elle a aussi un enfant qui a reçu une
injection et après cette injection son
enfant une paralysie
tout simplement parce qu'il n'avait pas
pu faire la différence entre ce
médicament et ce médicament alors
j'appelle j'en appelle à tout le monde
moi même qui suis dans l'étude aux mêmes
fins ou tic je ne pouvais pas fait sa
différence
[Musique]
pourquoi parce que dans ce médicament
qui prévient de convoyage du trail en
rien un médicament l'original et le
falsifiés ne sont pas vraiment différent
et quand il ya la composition du
médicament
c'est la capacité la proposition du
médicament qu'on peut réellement savoir
quel est le mais différents fichiers du
médicament original et comment se font
comment se fait la fabrication des
médicaments à la falsification des
médicaments se fait à plusieurs niveaux
nous avons des médicaments qui ne
possède pas des régions actives c'est à
dire les médias qui doit vous soigner
nous savons les médicaments qui
possèdent des ingrédients toxiques
nous avons des ingrédients 6 qui possède
différents ingrédients tels que par
exemple au lieu de l'amoxicilline on se
retrouve avec paris ce qu'un meuble dont
le médicament et nous avons eu affaire à
ces analyses le médicament on s'est
rendu compte que dans ces médicaments
trouvés on trouvait de la peinture des
poisons ou les femmes dans les
médicaments dès la crèche et de l'huile
de moteur
et où est ce que ces médicaments sont
faciles chez sept aps en france et ces
médicaments sont pacifiés dans les
grandes entreprises sont fabriqués en
les grandes entreprises non c'est
l'homme parfois les falsificateurs
produit ces médicaments dans des
chambres dans des toilettes
et puisqu'il veut tout ce qu'ils font
c'est à chuter le contenant le continent
ne doute pas du tout cher vous pouvez
avoir un continent à 0,8 0,05 dollar au
marché et je pense que si en produits et
médicaments dans cet état quelques potes
la composition du médicament l'activité
du médicament ne sera pas à ses idées
pourquoi est ce que les gens s'amusent à
contrefaire les médicaments
tout simplement parce que la
falsification des médicaments est la
contrefaçon la plus lucrative du monde
entier elle est plus lucratif que les
stupéfiants que les drogues
me tall a investi dans la pratique de
médicaments rapports entre deux sens
entre 200 billets 450 bipolar l'année or
dans le trafic d'héroïne de cocaïne et
1000 dollars investis rapport du 28
dollars les gens ne comprennent pas
parfois dans le club
la facilitation du médicament mais les
contrefacteurs ceux qui étaient dans le
domaine de des ventes de drogue se
livrent actuellement vers la
pacification du médicament et le
continent africain est le continent le
but visé il n'y a pas assez de
réglementation et pourquoi est ce que
l'afrique a visé tout simplement parce
que la free c'est un pays où nous avons
le plus de manager qui nécessitent des
médicaments essentiels quand médicaments
essentiels nous avons les matières
manquer les anti-pacs le lien qui sont
les plus faciles parce que vous savez la
malaria et la maladie qui sévit le plus
le continent africain et dans les
contrefacteurs ont compris que c'est ça
qu'il fallait investir pour pouvoir lui
plus de gains donc nous avons en premier
lieu les de la malaria est en italien en
bus du second lieu les antibiotiques et
puis on n'a pas laissé les
contrefacteurs qui n'ont pas laissé les
personnes atteintes du vih même cette
fête même ces médicaments sont aussi
fatigués en afrique uniquement la
pacification d'antipaludéens entraîne la
mort chaque année de 60 milles à 120
personnes
on tient accès tout l'université de
l'île du loup qui est décimée en une
année je pense mais plus encore et cette
même facilitation en afrique de 20 à 30
cents on observe dans les pays devant
être imposée
et même dans le pays ce toutes les
facilitations on va jusqu'à 50% alors vu
je veux que ce trafic est un trafic
assez important et qui entraîne l'herbe
et qui entraîna mans de plusieurs
africains ce que nous avons fait nous
avons commencé à développer de nouvelles
solutions
alors nous avons commencé à développer
des solutions qui s'appelle le trou ce
fait et qui utilise la défense est
officielle pour pouvoir analyser les
médicaments alors comment cela
fonctionne il suffit de mettre un
médicament aussi un appareil aspect
propre un spectromètre qui permet qui
fait à partir d'un rayonnement du
minable qui enverrait un rayonnement
lumineux ce médicament et enverra les
données du médicament via un téléphone
portable dans cette nouvelle technologie
permet de savoir la réelle composition
du médicament alors commencer la
fonctionnant en réalité un parti de
toutes ces données recueillies en pull
géolocaliser ses appareils dans ses
appareils juprelle exemple si dans la
ville de lubumbashi
on a dix mille appareils toutes les
analyses qui sont effectués avec ces
appareils seront jeu nos qualités on
peut dire ok chaque appareil
et dans la vie de magie pour un appareil
en amont a fait en une semaine on a fait
trois analystes et par les trois
analystes y avait deux faces aussi au
niveau de notre base du nez on aura tous
ces informations est en cours a donné
par exemple au gouvernement congolais
les informations à la fin de chaque
année sur l'importance du trafic
l'importance du trafic des faux
médicaments dans la zone de lubumbashi
précisément dans la zone du katanga du
grand clos mais alors comment est-ce que
cela se fait en faible constitution de
bases de données
inconscients du pasj donné la première
étape est de prendre
on travaille avec les laboratoires
certifiés oms on prend la composition
des vrais médicaments qui sont certifiés
par l'oms en france cette proposition on
est venu dans une base de données après
ça va nous c'est ces informations ne
s'est pas donné sa conduite unique aux
bases de données de référence et au fur
à mesure et pour l'analyse de
médicaments avec cet appareil
on a cette coupe qui donne l'information
chimiques de toutes les composantes du
médicament et là on prend part donc
l'analyste qui vient d'être effectuée à
la désinformation qui sont déjà en
respect dans nos clubs éliminés
et si l'intelligence artificielle va
comparer ces deux informations
c'est 2
en spectre des constituants et c'est ce
fait le nous le canton du pam
alors le médicament est pacifique et si
cette concorde
c'est à dire que c'est un bon médicament
basé sur une base de données de
référence
alors nous avons eu à effectuer nos
travaux une autre phase de notre phase
pilote au cameroun par exemple en rdc en
côte d'ivoire ils ont dit jamais un élan
de notre phase d'une autre phase pilote
nous avons eu à analyser près des cinq
médicaments et la grèce inquiète
médicaments nous avons eu plus de 2000
qui était facile et parler de mifa si
fier il y en a mais tu restes
contenaient des substances toxiques
c'est à dire à base de un poison de
souris à base d'huile de moteur
je prends 20 cas par exemple nous avons
un médecin qui s'appelle le dr dana une
nana qui a vu art souvent une passion
chez lui et le patient c'était un enfant
qui souffrait il y avait poussé dedans
et il avait prescrit un sirop à base de
paracétamol voix soul belgique mais la
mère de l'enfant est allé dans le format
6 h championnat et elle a eu
malheureusement pour elle c'était en
fait du de l'huile de moteur et venez
d'acheter et à crazy cela son enfant ait
décidé donc cela montre à quel point la
pacifique
et la facilitation et néfaste que notre
continent et c'est qu'il faudrait faire
c'est la facilitation des médicaments ce
n'est pas un problème de personne c'est
un problème de tous et plusieurs façons
qu'ont posé la question est ce que votre
appareil peut être utilisé dans le
domaine agroalimentaire du 18 bref
pourquoi parce que non pas pareille
crise donc j'ai dit le spectromètre est
trop cher en rouge qui permet on peut
réaliser des aliments il savoir à quels
sont les à l'échelle dans ses différents
aliments car il ya plusieurs personnes
aujourd'hui qui décèdent pas ce sont des
années j à des animaux et notre appareil
avait trappe à ressorts des savoirs
l'auto d'alléger le cv du top des cdc
différentes communes composant d'enter
dans des aliments est par exemple on a
lu un plusieurs on a eu en afrique sud
comme au cameroun par exemple
vague de rires en plastique qui était
vendu sur le marché et avec notre
appareil par exemple il suffit juste
d'analysé même à travers les concessions
le sac le sac et lui permet
ça va en fait si le le riz est un vie
normale je sais termine en plastique
comme comme on l'a déjà fait
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]